- Hello everybody, my
name is Spiros Xanthos
and together with Josh and Angelo,
we'll tell you a bit about, you know,
how we built and use
an AI SRE to help with,
to help troubleshoot
incidents around production.
I'm the founder, CEO of a
company called Resolve AI.
You have probably seen us
on your lanyards this week.
We built agents
that can use and run for tools
like a software engineer,
let's say, all production tools
from code to observability
to infrastructure,
with the goal, like I said,
of accelerating incident
troubleshooting, remediation,
but also helping run
production more broadly.
And today we're gonna share
information of how we,
what are the challenges in
building a product like this
and how can it be used in production.
A bit about myself,
I worked in observability
all of my career.
I previously built two companies,
a log analytics product
called Log Insight.
I dropped outta my PhD
to build that in 2008.
We ended up getting
acquired by VMware in 2012.
And then together with Mayank,
who's my co-founder at Resolve as well,
we co-created OpenTelemetry in 2018
and built a observability
platform called Omnition
around that.
At the time, our thesis was that
to build more powerful
observability solutions,
we had to essentially move
away from proprietary standards
and to, you know, open
telemetry in many ways.
Both provided an open standard,
but also an implementation
that we could use.
That company got acquired by Splunk
and then I had the luck to
run a large production system
with very strict SLAs.
And I saw first hand
how hard that is, right?
And we had times where we
would pose production bushes
for like a month, around
this time actually,
because many of our
customers were e-commerce.
And also there was a period of time
where 90% of our SRE team
resigned because of burnout.
And that was partially the motivation
for me and Mayank to work on Resolve,
to not create yet another
tool that humans can use,
but rather create agents
that work alongside humans
and make the life of, let's say,
SRE and software engineers better,
while also they improve the outcomes.
Now, software engineering in our view
is like two parts, right?
It's the coding and building,
and then it's the running
of the production.
And when you're writing code
or when you're creating software,
you have to have a lot of context
about production and vice versa.
When you're running production,
you need to understand
the application logic,
the infrastructure and all of that.
And what we have seen so
far is that, you know,
AI had already a lot of impact
in the coding part, right,
in the building of software.
I'm pretty sure many of you actually,
how many of you are using, let's say,
an agent to write code in production?
You know, we started obviously like,
probably two, three years ago
after GPT-3.5 with GitHub Copilot,
and that was more like
an assistant to a human,
more like auto completion.
Humans were still in the
driver's seat completely, but,
and of course it was like
the first wave in some sense
and we got some acceleration,
but still mostly we're
moving at the speed of,
let's say, human execution.
The second wave,
which I would say probably
landed about a year ago,
is when we started having
agents that, you know,
did more autonomous work
in creating code, right?
Essentially we moved from humans being,
let's say, the operator
of an ID almost now
to an agent being the operator
and the human now managing,
let's say the agent,
but still, you know, this
is for only a small part
of what the work of a software engineer is
in many ways, right?
We have some data statistics
and I'm curious for those of you
who work in bigger companies,
what is your take on this?
But really the time software engineers
spend in writing code is
usually like 10 to 20 to 30%,
especially for brownfield applications.
Of course, if you're starting new
and building a new application,
maybe you spend 80% of
your time writing code,
but that's usually not the case
when you're dealing with existing systems
that have been around for a while.
Where does the rest of the time go?
It's obviously goes into
maintaining, troubleshooting,
running, optimizing production.
And that's a very hard problem.
It's a very hard problem for humans
and it's a very hard problem for models.
Our view in some sense
is that models have solved
coding to some extent
and it's not uncommon to see
that 8% of code might
be generated by model.
But that doesn't mean we're moving,
let's say five times faster, right?
Because that's not enough
to accelerate the whole lifecycle
of software development and production.
Now why is this hard.
This is hard
because if you're dealing with
the entire software stack,
right, the whole production system,
you're dealing not just with code,
which is obviously an
important part of it,
but now you're dealing
with a lot of tools.
Think of like observability
tools, CICD pipelines,
many times we have multiple
of these tools that,
and they were not
designed to work together.
The data is siloed.
Oftentimes we even have like two tools
for the same type of data, right?
It's not uncommon that
your infrastructure metrics
might be living in one tool
and then your application
metrics in another tool.
And of course then you
have also infrastructure
that by itself is very dynamic and complex
and again, it's not uncommon
that somebody might be running
across multiple clouds.
Now, on top of all this
complexity, let's say of tooling,
it takes multiple, let's say
different types of expertise
to run a production system.
It takes, you know, there is,
and you know, oftentimes
let's say this expertise
might be combined in a single human right,
we have oftentimes application developers
who are on-call and manage
infrastructure as well, right?
But in reality it's kind of
a different skill to write,
let's say, an application
versus to manage a platform
or to even like debug an
infrastructure problem.
And then on top of that,
unlike let's say code
that is self-documenting,
for the most part,
production is never fully documented.
Usually the knowledge
of how to run production
lives across tools, let's say,
your dashboards, your alerts,
across documents, runbooks,
SOPs, prior incidents,
but oftentimes just in human minds.
And that's what makes
it very, very difficult
for any human in reality,
but also for for AI as well.
And what is the effect of all that?
You know, reliability
obviously is a priority
for anyone who delivers,
you know, the business
through software and,
but it usually comes at a very
high cost of humans, tools
and oftentimes it's not even achieved
despite this very high cost.
It's not gonna be
uncommon if you ask a CTO
what to rank their expenses,
they will tell you, of course,
engineers is the top expense.
You know, maybe the cloud is a second,
observability is my third.
But despite all that, you know, war rooms
and you know, escalations are
very, very common occurrence
and oftentimes involved tens of people.
And even in scenarios where, let's say,
you have maybe an a network
operations center, right?
Or like L1 SRE versus, you
know, software engineer on-call,
typically escalations happen all the time.
The other thing we see often
and have some very
interesting stories to share,
maybe afterwards you have
time, is that infrastructure,
extremely infrastructure
observability comes at a huge cost
'cause they're very over-provisioned.
We're actually in our effort
to ensure when something goes wrong,
we have the data to
troubleshoot the problem.
Obviously we collect
as much datas possible
and then also an infrastructure
itself is over-provisioned
to ensure like if something goes wrong
or you know, if you have
a spike you can handle it.
And you know,
brownfield development in particular
is a very, very huge challenge
because of the complexity
and you know, the large system
and the lack of, let's say it is difficult
for any human to know the entire system.
So we see very commonly in, you know,
when we talk to our customers
or even from our own experience,
that there's usually a small
set of humans that are experts
and you know, instead
of maybe being building
or architecting, they end
up firefighting all the time
because obviously when
something goes wrong,
it takes precedence over everything else.
And you know, usually when a new engineer
or SRE joins an organization,
it takes them probably a week
to submit the first PR
but takes them up six months or longer
to be primary on-call.
And why is that?
Because there is so much
context that you need to absorb.
You might have all the
expertise as a human, right?
You are probably an expertise SRE
but then you join a new organization
and you know, you have
to learn all the things
about that production
system that is quite unique
compared to what you've seen before.
And of course when an expert resigns,
you don't just lose their skills,
you lose all this accumulated
experience about the system.
And of course AI generated
code just makes this all worse.
Just focusing on maybe
the most painful part
of running a production system,
which is being on-call and
dealing with incidents.
It is quite common to see
situations where first of all,
maybe if you're the
person that gets called
to troubleshoot the problem,
usually you have a call start, right?
It's a very stressful situation
to be in as an individual.
It's probably one of the hardest things
when at three in the morning,
let's say you get paged
and you have to go figure
out what's going on
with all the pressure of
what if I don't do right?
All the downside effects of that, right?
We also see quite common to
have like huge incident tunnels
with like, sorry,
with 20 plus people
or it's not even uncommon
to have like especially
larger enterprises,
situations where maybe
one team gets paged,
they don't solve the problem,
another team gets paged,
a third thing gets paged,
they don't solve the problem
until you end up like
in the networking team
because it's the DNS, I suppose.
And you have all these people
now in a Slack channel,
maybe a hundred of them
trying to figure out
what's going on, right?
And you often even see that
maybe people remediate the problem
but then the actual cause is
not found for another few days.
And I think especially now
that we started generating a lot of code,
but not only because of that, right,
like we're creating a lot more software,
a lot more technology.
And that's very desirable
in my view, right,
like that's good for the world.
But you know, managing all that software
becomes a lot harder.
And you know, we have
like fragmented tools,
we have, you know, very large systems
that it's impossible for any
human to know by themselves.
And to some degree, maybe like the silo
can kind of effect we
have is desirable, right?
For anyone who tried maybe to
go through a transformation
and maybe, you know,
implement observability,
you know how hard it is to move
from one system to another, right?
And oftentimes maybe one,
one tool is very good for infrastructure.
Another tool is very good for applications
and maybe it's desirable
to have these, you know,
data separated and used
by different tools.
But okay, what is, I guess,
the solution to all of these problems
I talked about?
So we do believe that we're about to move
or we're in the process of
moving to this third wave of AI,
let's say in software
engineering, more broadly,
that applies to software
engineering, NSRE,
which is, let's say humans
until let's say maybe two years ago,
were both the operator of
all the tools they had,
you know, in a development environment
and also the glue across them, right?
For most tasks you probably
have to look into code,
you have to look into logs,
you have to understand your infrastructure
and combine the information
to get to some task completed.
I think now we have moved to maybe
oftentimes agents being the operators
of these tools individually
and then a human is the glue, right?
So you might have an
agent write code for you,
you might even have an agent
that can query system
better than you can do it,
but then you still are the person
who's a human is stitching
together the information.
But I think we're about
to move to this new world,
let's say, where agents are
both the operators and the glue
and the humans will be operating
at a higher level of abstraction.
And we think that's the path forward.
But this path forward involves
essentially a few things,
right, that are very, very hard.
But I think we're getting there
and if I have an insight
to serve from my experience
working day and night with AI
for the last couple of years
is that I think agents are
gonna work in production
as well as they work for code today
and we're actually almost there
and the impact is gonna be even bigger
'cause these are harder and more stressful
and more painful problems.
But of course to do that we
need to be able essentially
to take the expertise of humans
across all of these different disciplines
and kind of encode it into agents
or give the agents the
tools that humans possess.
We need to understand,
make the agents understand and
operate all the human tools
because obviously all
the software environments
in the world today were
built for humans to operate.
So agents have to essentially
learn how to operate
and understand these
environments the way human would
and maybe the hardest
or the most important
is that each environment is unique.
So we have to be able to
build agents that kind of
can both discover knowledge
the way human would,
but also learn from
every interaction, right?
So over time they become better and better
at working with alongside
humans in getting results.
And it's not a frustrating experience.
And of course as you maybe all know,
models don't have memory.
So this is a very, very hard part
of building an agentic system
because all of that has to happen
outside of the ways of the model.
And that's kind of the
solution we built at Resolve,
basically we are a multi-agent system.
Maybe a simple way to think about it,
like your typical coding
agent is one agentic loop
with probably 10 to 20
tools that the agent can use
to produce code, understand
and produce code.
Resolve is about 10 of those,
for code, logs, metrics,
infrastructure, knowledge documents
that we all have to work
together in accomplishing tasks.
The most common tasks
humans use Resolve for
is to be on-call, troubleshoot
and remediate alerts and incidents.
And typically every, any
alert involves going,
let's say from code to metrics to logs,
back and forth a few times,
as you probably have know those of you
who have have done this type of work
until it gets an answer.
But also if you think about it,
most tasks humans have to do in production
have similar characteristics.
And that's why we believe
that by building a multi-agentic system
that can operate the tools as a human,
that can learn from humans
and allows humans to now
essentially instruct this system
almost like a junior engineer
can be very, very
effective in accelerating
and how we run production systems,
but also making our lives easier
at an individual level, right,
like it's not as painful
hopefully if you get paged
at three in the morning
or maybe you don't even get paged anymore
at three in the morning, right?
An agent gets paged
and if it not solve the problem,
then you know you are
the escalation point.
And one thing that maybe I would say
that surprised me in building Resolve
is how quickly,
when we started the company,
we didn't even know people
will trust an AI in production.
And now you know, we are working
with some of the largest,
you know, technology and
finance services companies
in the world
and are very surprised by
how quickly people adopt it
or (indistinct) has adopted this
and you know, Angelo,
who's here from Coinbase,
can explain that part in a bit.
But with that I'm gonna pass it on to Josh
who's gonna give some more details
about the technology and give a demo.
- I get the exciting part
so I get to do the demo,
but I'm also standing
in the way of Angelo,
so I know you're all here
to to hear from Coinbase.
So I want to give you a little glimpse
into how the product works,
how it's used, and let's jump in.
So we're here to talk about
AI for incidents, AI SRE,
that's what's commonly referred to today.
However, when you think about an AI SRE,
there's a lot it can do beyond
just resolving incidents,
resolving incidents is kind
of starting with the pinnacle,
the hardest part of the equation
because of these complex systems,
everything is changing,
knowledge is locked up in
each individual's heads
as well as unstructured and
structured datacross systems.
And interestingly, when
Spiros and I were doing a demo
early on in the days,
probably about a year and a half ago,
to a head of technology,
I think the world's largest
music streaming company,
the thing that he saw
when he saw us do an incident walkthrough,
so an alert fires,
we triage it,
within minutes, you have a root cause.
He said, "Hey, this is amazing."
He's like, "But what I really see here
is giving us those incremental gains
and keeping my engineers
in their flow state."
Because what an SRE does
is not just incidents,
they're kind of that
catchall for everything
about your operations.
Whether it's platform engineering,
how does CICD work,
let's optimize our costs,
let's do capacity planning and so forth.
But by starting with incidents,
if you do that really well,
it unlocks everything else.
There's a new book out by Nicole Forsgren
called "Frictionless."
And it talks a lot about
developer experience
and friction created by the systems,
the adoption of AI in the
new world plus the old world.
And what she latches onto
is the importance of keeping individuals
in their flow state.
So giving them the autonomy to actually go
and get context when they
need it to unblock themselves.
She also talks about cognitive load
and reducing that cognitive
load through abstractions
and new modern tools.
And so what I wanna show you in the demo
is not only the incidents
because that's what you're here to see,
but I also wanna show you
what the possibilities are
in using tools like this.
So I've worked with Spiros and Mayank
many times previously in Omnition.
What we learned in building
observability tools
or any developer tool
is you kind of want to embed yourself
into the workflow already.
And so a common way to use Resolve
is directly through Slack.
Many of you, if you've
been in incidents before,
you're part of these alert channels
or when an incident is declared,
a channel is spun up.
And this could be in
Teams, Slack, wherever.
And what ends up happening
is you're given something like this,
an alert you're probably
not that familiar with,
it doesn't have a lot more
than probably a dashboard
that you're gonna follow.
You're gonna look at a bunch of panels,
then you're gonna go
and drum up a log query.
You're gonna start to page folks.
Let's look how Resolve that works.
So there's kind of two different ways
that Resolve gets triggered.
One is autonomously.
So an alert fires, a web hook
shoots out, or an API call
and Resolve goes to work.
The other is through natural language.
I'm gonna take you through
that in a little bit.
So when this alert fires, it
says the front-end error logs,
it looks like there's really
just front-end error logs,
some labels and so forth.
That's the alert rule.
Now what's interesting
about this alert is,
if you were to investigate this,
the first thing you want us
to do is see that error spike.
And you might wanna look
at what those logs show you on errors,
but this gets a little bit more complex.
This is a nested investigation.
Here you see the findings
that it actually was a dependency service
that was cascading errors
to the front-end, okay?
We check the infrastructure
and we also see that
there was a deployment.
What do you know, change
caused this incident.
Now the hard part about Slack is,
there's context in here,
we wanna make it actionable
so that you can remediate immediately.
If you want, you can create
a PR right from here.
However, when you're in an incident,
you actually want all that
knowledge at your fingertips,
all the data.
And so let's look at the UI
so that you can start to see
the work that Resolve is doing.
And where I want to take you first
is I wanna expose you to how it works.
The reason being is 'cause
then you're gonna start
to get those wheels turning
to see exactly what
you can do with Resolve
and all the entry points for context
to help us understand your systems.
So here's that same alert that fired.
This is just the payload
coming directly from grafana.
But you're gonna start to
see Resolve go to work.
So it's not just like a zero star RCA,
like give us an error
and we're gonna go and troubleshoot it.
What we're doing is
we're relying on explicit
and implicit data.
So we call that knowledge.
We're understanding your system.
So we're building a topology
or an understanding what
we call a knowledge graph.
I'll show you that in a second.
And we're even looking through history,
we're accessing tools.
And so what Resolve does
is it generates a plan.
This a plan is multi-step by nature.
It's gathering evidence.
It knows how to drum up the queries,
it understands rate limits,
it understands the tools,
it knows where the data lives.
And as you can see through here,
it's going through each individual step.
We're looking at logs.
Here, we generate eight
different log queries.
These are very precise log queries,
understanding exactly
what we're looking for.
They don't have to be
generated by the alert itself.
We can generate them ourselves.
Then we start to look at
some of the historicals.
So one big part about AI,
especially in this use case is,
we can have an investigation
that looks beautiful that
we're like, you know what,
we checked all the right things.
It checks out from our experience,
but it still takes humans
to resolving incidents
and providing that feedback
or to be in a part of those channels
where we see the remediation take place
for us to understand if it's good.
So we look at historical investigations,
we create memories from those.
Then we start to look
at some of your traces.
Again, we wanna see where those spans,
especially in a complex
microservices environment
where those error spans look.
We're gonna look at your logs,
your infrastructure events.
Again, change exists everywhere.
If you just plug this into your code,
you don't actually know
when that PR goes into production or not.
You may know when it's merged.
We look at charts and dashboards.
So a lot of what we have to do
is we have to understand
your observability systems,
not just what's within there,
but how they're used just
like a human would be.
So we're understanding
what are the dashboards
that are commonly used?
What do these dashboards mean?
How are the panels used?
And we allow you to embed
information as well within there.
And now we start to update
the investigation report.
We're looking at the code,
again, like we can have
some great theories
with high confidence,
but without checking the
code to see the intent
behind what happened,
we're not gonna get to causality.
We're still gonna be at
that correlation phase.
And finally we end up here.
So here we've got a working theory.
This working theory, it
does have high confidence.
So this was a cascading event.
Now, one important part about AI,
especially where when
you think about the folks
that are doing this type of
work, incidents themselves,
they pride themselves on
understanding the data,
knowing where to look, what it looks like,
seeing those anomalies firsthand.
And so you have to provide
that same type of information directly.
So we're providing the
logs that we've queried,
we're providing charts,
these are all made on the fly.
So we're not ingesting all
of your observability data
and then acting on this.
We're actually querying it in real time.
We're generating these
queries on ourselves
or using what exists within dashboards.
Now as you go through,
this is where it gets really interesting,
if you're escalated too.
Say you were part of this incident,
you are gonna see a bunch
of different theories.
You're gonna see a bunch of people
that are posting charts
in that Slack channel.
But the reality is what you want is,
you wanna understand the
timeline of the events.
You want to see how big the impact is
and you wanna understand what
those errors were telling you
because this is where your
intuition is gonna kick in, okay?
And then finally, any recommendations
and any supporting information.
And so as you can imagine,
this seems like a simple incident.
The amount of work that
takes place in people's heads
and the tools that you're using
to get here is overloaded.
So seeing that that is an
incident, we do that all day.
So an alert fires
or an incident channel is spun up,
Resolve goes to work.
Now let's see what we can actually do
with this information as well.
So we've got two different interfaces.
So one of course Slack,
your collaboration tool,
the other one is UI.
Resolve can be triggered
via natural language
because when you think about it,
if you have a question,
you wanna understand
the health of the system
or maybe one of these incidents
that actually starts in customer support
where someone's complaining
about errors on the front-end,
you might want to chat
directly with Resolve.
So you can do this directly
outta Slack or within Resolve.
But you know what, let's
take a new use case.
So, "I'm new here.
Tell me about our AWS infrastructure,"
sorry, it helps me to read
out loud while I'm typing
"and services.
Format it in a table,"
because I'm a visual person.
So when you think about
when you've joined your
last engineering role
or when you hire somebody,
chances are you expect them
to ship their first PR in week one.
But that's because you've
created this surface area
of understanding that they
need that's this small.
However, what, how long does
it take for them to go on-call?
It's what, three to four months?
And the reason being is one, it's context.
It's understanding the
complexity of the systems,
but it's also having the confidence
to know that what to do.
Because you know those
runbooks, those SOPs,
they're not kept up to date.
And so here, just within 30 seconds or so,
we've kind of created a wrapper here.
So we'll talk a little bit
about the integrations.
But here what we're doing
is we're essentially using the AWS CLI
to generate all of our
AWS information here.
So we've got EC2 instances,
we've got RDS, MSK and so forth.
Now if I'm new here and I'm curious,
I might wanna say, hey,
"Tell me more about RDS.
What services read
and write to it."
Maybe, "Draw a mermaid diagram."
Because those are really in, okay.
And so here, what we're gonna do now
is when we need to understand RDS
and we need to know the dependencies,
let's show you how we get there.
So I'm gonna flip over
to the integrations view.
So interestingly enough,
one of the biggest challenges
that we had early on was,
hey, this looks like magic.
But we all know it's not magic.
You still need to connect all the tools
that a human might use to troubleshoot.
And that's absolutely true.
We had to put guardrails in place
just so we went to overstep initially
when we knew we didn't have the right data
that we needed access to.
And so we've got dozens of integrations.
Everything from your
integrations, I'm sorry,
your infrastructure yourself,
observability tools,
unstructured data, even
where tickets are created.
Now, right now you're looking
at this in read-only mode.
But you can imagine if
we can get to an RCA,
why can't we create a Jira ticket?
Why can't we actually daisy
chain or create a PR ourselves?
Okay, so those are the,
those are the integrations themselves.
Now what we do with those integrations
is we build what's
called a knowledge graph.
Now this is my least
favorite part of the product
'cause I think it's hideous
and no one ever uses these,
but everybody wants one.
Here, this is a simple
application, 19 services,
but it's a microservices application.
It's got a lot of dependencies as well.
Now what's interesting about
this is we maintain this
because when you think about
understanding anomalies
or spikes or anything like that,
you actually need a temporal
view of your entire system.
And so we create this on the
fly using these integrations
as well as other contexts that we create.
And that's what we use
for these investigations
as well as to know where to go next, okay.
If we go back into chat,
I'm actually gonna take you
into one that's completed
just 'cause I know I'm
gonna get kicked off stage.
I did this just right before this session,
but this is the same exact chat.
So here we see the database architecture,
the connected services,
there's our beautiful mermaid diagram.
And fun fact as we never
create any diagrams ourselves
by hand anymore because of this.
Key insights limited database usage,
so only two services are running.
I followed up with
another question though.
I said, you know what?
I wanna know about the health of RDS.
'cause every company I've gone to,
they run into issues with Postgres.
Tell me if see any anomalies or spikes.
So now let's look at what it did.
So it took a look at all
these charts and dashboards.
You can see the queries that it's running.
So it needs to know that hey,
we're going to performance
insights to find this,
we need to look at these dashboards.
And again, every time
I go into an incident
and I click into grafana,
there are about 14 different variables
that I have to select
before I get to what I need,
even if that dashboard is attached.
This does it all for you,
and in parallel.
And here's the report that was published.
So you see key metrics, CPU utilization,
there were some spikes
detected and there's a pattern.
Here are two different
spikes that occurred.
So in the early morning we
see that this is unusual,
so a CPU spiked.
In the evening,
we're seeing a reoccurring daily pattern.
The same pattern observed
in previous days' data.
Here, what we found was
the CPU spike to, wow, 343%
and the right latency was there.
In fact, it actually automatically went
and root caused it itself.
And so here we see that
there was a resource,
intensive SQL query.
It show, it builds a
chart telling you exactly
what that query resulted in,
why this is problematic.
So again, using the code as well.
And here are the positive
findings, making recommendations.
And so one of the hard parts about this is
not everything is a root cause.
Sometimes you just want us to do a task.
That's what SRE do.
You go into ask engineering at work
because you wanna just understand
why am I getting errors here?
For this one, it decided
to do an investigation
because of these anomalies.
When I asked which service
is making the query
and can you generate it?
Of course it can.
So here, what it's gonna do
is it's gonna investigate the code
to understand where that query came from.
It's gonna find the root cause
and now it's gonna generate that PR.
Creating a PR is as easy as this, okay?
And this is kind of the difference
between cogen tools
and what Resolve offers
is we know what production looks like.
It's not theoretical anymore.
Here are the changes that were
made, the expected impact.
Now using knowledge that's
created within here,
if you want to, you can
actually just enrich
with our resolve markdown file,
how you wanna interface with Resolve.
So if you want to add any
runbook, any nomenclature,
anything that we can't pick
up from, say your notion,
your Atlassian, then
you can do that as well.
Last night I created a slash command.
Here, what it's doing is it's
formatting a postmortem. Okay?
So this is the power.
This is what an AI SRE should be.
It's really an AI for productions.
It's not about just incidents,
it's what that enables you to do.
Because what we see
is it's more than just engineers
that are on-call using this,
is really every engineer
that has to create, that has to innovate,
that has to write code,
and they want to know
the impact of their code.
So let's jump back into the slides
and we'll talk a little bit
more about how we built this.
So there are really three critical aspects
for what we've built.
The first one is that it understands.
So that knowledge graph, that idea,
so when you think about
like what is a human,
when you look at those principle engineers
and you're like, wow, like we want them
on the most critical project,
what is it about them?
It's they know all the history,
they know how the system works,
they've seen all the fault patterns,
they've read all the postmortems,
they probably wrote 60% of them.
They also have that experience.
So they've learned through the process,
they've seen all the refactors
and been a part of those.
And then they've developed that intuition,
that ability to reason.
When they've given a piece of data,
they kind of know the sniff test.
Resolve has to do the same thing.
So we have to build that
understanding of the system,
but we don't have the luxury of time.
We have to do it through integrations
and what's already available, okay?
And so that's the knowledge graph.
Now learning is where it
gets really interesting
because we're, I'm sure
if you're starting to
or already involved in AI,
you understand the concepts of memory
and even these markdown files
if you're using cursor and so forth.
For us it's a little bit different
because there's paper trails everywhere
in terms of how people use tools,
meaning like we know the
most common dashboards
that are used.
Why wouldn't we use that
information to understand
how we should navigate your systems?
Or if people are say
everything has a P1 label
within your alerts,
why wouldn't we investigate those
or at least put that as a rubric.
During an incident itself,
if you're going to have a channel
where everybody's working through it
and you're getting all the way
to causality and remediation,
why wouldn't we learn from that?
These are all system interactions.
Additionally, we provide a layer
where you can add your own context
and this context can be
added at a team level,
an organizational level and so forth.
And that's additional
knowledge that we use to inform
how we answer questions
in the tools that we use.
There's always say proprietary information
that you might have that you want to share
so that we can be even more effective.
Now the reasoning piece
is really interesting
because what happens is every
single prompt that you see,
it's really sending a
message to us to say,
hey, go do something with that.
And so we have this planner.
This planner is essentially the brains.
It's saying, okay, given this
prompt, what should we do?
And that prompt can be
a payload from alert,
it can also be natural language.
What it does then is it goes
and it calls these sub-agents
that are specialized agents
to go and gather evidence.
Now they go out.
We have to respect rate
limits, understand the systems,
how they operate,
understand the payloads
that we're gonna return.
We have to process those as as well.
Once it receives that information,
it needs to create additional plans, okay?
So what other evidence,
based on what I saw,
all of that comes out into that response.
But it doesn't typically stop there
because of the feedback loops.
So a lot of the time
there's a human in the loop.
That's what makes it so successful.
And this is part of the
UX that's so difficult
is how do we make sure that a human knows
that this information you can guide,
you can say, hey, last time we heard
there was something over here,
can you go check?
A human doesn't wanna make that check,
but we can do it for you.
And so that's where
the response comes out.
And then we go back through another loop.
Now when we are building resolve,
so back historically when we got started,
the context windows weren't
even large enough for logs.
So a lot of the error logs
where the root cause lived,
we couldn't even process
with foundation bottoms at that time.
So you can imagine how
effective it could be
in getting to root cause.
Now a lot of companies though,
they're starting to dabble with this,
whether it's in a
hackathon or in production,
because this is ripe for disruption.
And this is a pain point that
every engineer lives with,
which is understanding the system,
having the agency to access the tools
and get access to
knowledge that they need.
And so what a lot of folks do,
and these were those first
like glimmers of hope
is you just take an error that spits out,
you throw it into a foundation model
and you see what comes out.
Now a lot of times those
recommendations are pretty logical.
Sometimes it nails it.
But the reality is that this
doesn't work in complex systems
and pretty much in any system
with any level of reliability
'cause you need the context,
you need to understand the code,
you need to understand
all of these other layers beyond that.
And so what a lot of folks
move to is now with MCP,
interestingly enough, being
in AI, you're always like,
is this an opportunity?
Is this a threat?
What does it mean?
With MCP servers,
what we found is now we
have access to systems
and motivated customers
to build MCP servers
to access data that
wasn't readily available.
Maybe it's legacy systems.
Now the challenge though
with just using LLMs and MCP
is say you run a query
to your observability,
maybe it's natural language
or you say, you know what,
we're getting errors from here.
It can go and process that request.
But what's it gonna do with it?
You kind of need state, you need context.
There's also additional prompting you need
around say handling times
like do I check a one hour or a week?
What happened historically?
How do I know this is anomalous?
However, this can get you
a little bit of value.
Right out of the gate is
just using the MCP servers
that are available,
but it's not gonna get
you to complex problems.
'cause you still have to
understand both the historical
but also the context
as you daisy change
these systems together.
And so what a lot of folks are doing,
especially as foundation
models get even stronger
is they're going to agents.
Now you can build an agent
that understands a lot of context,
it connects to a lot of,
it can make a lot of different NCP calls.
Ideally there's security and governance
within there that you're
taking care of as well.
You also have to build the
user experience for that.
But what ends up happening
is you're putting
so much context into these events
that have happened historically,
meaning like you're
learning from past events
and so you're adding runbooks to it
and you're trying to give
all these directives.
What ends up happening is one,
it becomes bloated, it becomes slow.
But two, it's not prepared
to handle novel incidents
but also novel questions,
prompts it hasn't seen before.
And that's why the single agent approach
really starts to break down.
And then finally, multi-agent systems,
that's where we've ended up.
The challenge here
though is orchestration.
So not only do you need domain expertise
for every single one of these
agents that you produce,
whether it's processing
logs, metrics, code
for these specific use cases,
but you also need to
understand rate limits.
You also need to understand
failure patterns.
You need to create an eval system.
Those fail patterns.
If we don't get results
from say the trace agent,
how do we reconcile that?
These are all things
that you have to consider
when you're building this.
And so the complexity,
just like moving to microservices did,
yes, it created a lot of like agility,
smaller teams, smaller surface areas.
Everything's API driven.
But then you have to orchestrate it all.
And here we are with Kubernetes
and so we're seeing them all.
The good news is most companies
have something homegrown
and usually it's complimentary.
It's just an input into the
systems, like what we've built.
So now let's hear about
Coinbase journey into AI SRE
and what Angelo has been working on.
- Thank you Josh.
Imagine it's a Friday afternoon
and you're trying to unwind for the week
when all of a sudden you
hear that dreaded sound
coming from your phone, right?
You really don't want to hear that,
but you are on-call, you just got paged.
There's a problem in production.
You have to do something,
you have to get online
and resolve the problem.
You still don't know
exactly what is wrong.
You dunno how long it will
take to restore the service.
It's not great.
Your boss is even maybe
asking you questions
on chat.
Anyone familiar with the experience?
Yeah, raise your hand.
We have a few. Yeah, okay.
I've seen many of of these
events unfortunately,
and I'm go and try to
in the next 10 minutes
to show how we can we have improved
or we plan to improve this in the future.
So my name is Angelo.
I'm a software engineer at Coinbase
in the infrastructure team
where we build the foundational components
on top of which the
products are developed.
And in my time, I spend a lot of time
investigating incidents also
preventing them from happening,
you know, leading the response when
they inevitably do happen.
My relationship with the AI,
initially, was kind of a skeptic, right?
Until a few years ago,
I thought like many other people
that these were just fancy
auto completion tools.
They're may be helpful
to generate some scripts
that you would throw away the next day,
but I was proven wrong actually,
sometime in 2023 I realized this,
this is actually much bigger than that.
I realized that it can
actually help professionals
build software much faster
at a way greater speed.
And it can enable
companies to build products
and iterate really much more quickly.
So this has an impact on the tech industry
as a whole, on economy.
And I believe in even
on society, eventually.
So I kinda had this moment.
For those who are not
familiar with Coinbase,
it's a, well,
it's a cryptocurrency
exchange founded in 2012
that allows more than 120
million people worldwide
to trade over 40,000 crypto assets.
And we have a total of almost
like over half trillion dollars in assets
that we have on our platform.
So our system has grown
a lot, scaled a lot.
And in order to sustain this business,
our infrastructure has also developed,
grown a lot.
We went from a Ruby on Rails Monolith,
that was running just on EC2,
to a complex network of
thousands of services
deployed on Kubernetes clusters
and on hundreds of them.
And we have all sorts of data stores
that for specific use cases.
Now we have solved one problem,
but there's nothing for free, of course.
Now, it's all much more
complicated to understand.
No one really understands the full system
and when things go wrong,
who can really fix it in a good time,
in a short time.
So Coinbase has been a very
positive in enabling,
in adopting AI tools since the beginning.
And that's good.
So now we have all
engineers use some AI tool
to write code, to review, to summarize,
to get familiar with new code base.
There are all sorts of
use cases that help,
that accelerate the, you know,
the act of writing software.
And, this has been,
our CEO has encouraged internally
and externally to adopt them.
But their use has been
limited to code only.
We got to the point
that writing code is
no longer a bottleneck.
It's fast.
It is not the issue anymore.
And as it happens with software,
you optimize one function
that is the bottleneck.
Now, you're gonna see something else
that becomes the bottleneck.
Now it's, you are gonna see
that you spend more time
maybe waiting for the code review
or waiting for some approval
or maybe for the build to finish,
to deploy or something like that.
But there's also another thing
that maybe it's a bit overlooked
and it's the operations of
the production environment,
which is now more complex,
the operations and the debugging
when it doesn't go as it as expected.
So that's the topic that we wanted to,
the kind of the question we ask ourselves,
is it possible to use AI for production
similarly to how we all used
AI tools to generate code?
And to be honest,
I didn't know at the beginning
and now, I can say
that I'm optimistic about this,
but you have the right to be skeptic
as I was a skeptic too in the past.
So we decided to start with incidents
because incidents are very time consuming
and stressful events
and no one really likes,
but you know, they happen.
We have to deal with them.
Lots of people,
lots of engineers get together in a room
trying to figure out what's the problem.
There's a cost, there's
an engineering cost,
there's a context switch
and also an impact on the business
because users are probably not happy
about what happened during an incident.
Now can we make this faster
or can we resolve this faster?
And so we decided to try Resolve
as a potential tool
to help us make this a bit less painful.
And it turns out that it is possible.
We had some criteria
that we wanted to follow
some principles that say, okay,
if we manage to get all these check boxes,
then we can actually
adopt it in production.
So we trained the agent
on real life incidents
that happened in the recent past
with the real metrics and everything.
And then compared what is
the answer of the agent
versus what happened in reality
when engineers were there,
like trying to debug.
And then we also simulated the
like kind of vague prompts.
We simulated an engineer
who doesn't have deep domain knowledge
on whatever was broken.
So that kind of this
levels up the engineers,
even if you're not the
expert on service X,
you can still make some progress
towards the root cause
by using these tools.
We found in some cases it
wasn't able to get like,
deep to the real root cause.
And almost always it was
because of missing data,
it didn't have enough context,
enough knowledge to get to the root cause.
So in practice we used
only two data sources,
Kubernetes and Datadog,
so Resolve can access, can
see what the pods are up to,
what, how they evolve over time.
And they can read metrics,
login traces from Datadog.
It can do a lot more.
But these are the only two
that we have integrated so far.
We also gave you some general knowledge
and you can see, you can imagine this
as the knowledge that a new engineer
acquires in their first week at a company.
You're learn like all the things that are,
how to deploy code,
what are the best practice,
what are the conventions
we use in this company?
They're like different
from anyone else, right?
And then, I mean, the following
weeks as a new engineer,
you learn about the
team specific knowledge
and this is also what
we talked to the agent.
So we combined data
sources, general knowledge
and team specific knowledge
or runbooks, right?
And this really improved
the performance at the end.
The performance in terms
of speed was pretty good.
It was able in most
cases to find root cause
of a real incident a lot faster
and have a greater than 50% accuracy,
which meant it was able to
get to the real root cause.
And as I said before, this can be improved
by adding more data sources.
One of the most important
would be the source code.
As Spiros was mentioning before,
if you give the agent
access to the source code,
it can do much deeper analysis.
It can understand what line of code
responsible for the problem
and maybe even suggest
a fix, potential PR.
I have two example incidents.
We're almost at a time.
But this is an example of incident,
just a screenshot from the Resolve
where this was caused by
a badly tuned load test.
We constantly load test
our services in production
to make sure that they can scale anytime
to respond to volatility events.
And in this case, one
endpoint was hit really badly,
very slow test.
Resolve was able to traverse
the dependency graph of our services
and get to the service that was suffering,
had like very high CPU utilization.
It reached all the HPA limits
and also was aware that
there was a load test
because we taught the agent the concept
of load test at Coinbase,
which is different from
other organizations,
like it's very specific to organization.
A second one
was caused by an out of memory
error in a sidecar container.
Again, this was like deep into the
service dependency graph,
from outside it looked
like there were, like,
tens of different endpoints
that were affected were
failing with five hundreds.
But it was kinda hard to get to the,
to get to the root cause.
And all the services that were failing,
they all had in common
this sidecar container
that was running out of memory.
Resolve was able to
find that in 12 minutes.
However, due to the limitation,
because it cannot access the source code,
it cannot know why, right?
And that had to be done,
that has to be done manually right now.
Okay, so how do we use Resolve today?
We basically do invoke it manually
on a chat bot interface
or from Slack as you saw before.
But in the future we are gonna use it
and other investigation also
whenever there's an alert.
But in the future, I
hope we can integrate it
so that it can propose
remediation actually.
And you know, in the future,
in the next few years,
I expect that these agents will become
more kind of, more autonomous,
will give them a bit more freedom
to operate and to suggest
and even make changes to our environments.
And we'll see that as
a kind of natural thing
that now seems a bit something
that we wouldn't trust.
Like I wasn't trusting,
in the past, I wasn't trusting
an AI tool to write code,
but then I realized it was
a good idea to trust it.
I think we're probably
gonna see something similar,
a similar shift in two
or three years from now.
And with that,
I am done.
If you are interested in
knowing about Coinbase,
you can check out this link
or you wanna chat with me.
You can find me, you
know, here or on LinkedIn
and (faintly speaks).
- So anybody,
Angelo is one of my
favorite people to work with
'cause he's obviously very thorough
of very extremely high bar
and, you know, getting past that bar,
I mean his bar, of course,
in the Coinbase bar
makes me extremely happy.
And you know, what we managed to achieve,
of course with Coinbase both past the bar,
let's say of like very
high quality engineers,
obviously that, you know,
wouldn't, like, use a tool
unless it's very effective,
but also very high compliance
and security environment at the same time.
I have two questions.
A year ago, actually,
it was the first time I gave a demo,
it was I think maybe
around reinvent to Coinbase
and the reaction was, oh,
this looks very useful,
but we'll never use AI
in production, I guess,
or an AI tool like this.
What changed over the past one year?
- I guess never say never, right?
Because that's the same thing
I would think, you know,
three years ago I wouldn't let a AI agent
to write code for me.
They didn't know how to write
code, but they actually do.
So what changed?
Maybe we had that red pill moment
that we realized this
has a very high potential
and security is obviously paramount.
It's very important.
We cannot compromise on that.
But once you understand the system,
you understand what it can do.
You can put guardrails right on the agent,
so you know it's not gonna do
anything that is not allowed.
Yeah, so I guess we've spent
a lot of time together,
- Correct. Correct.
- Yeah.
- By the way, and the
other question I have is,
you made the prediction, all right,
you said you were skeptic, you know,
you started believing in code,
you started believing now
in agents for production.
If your prediction goes wrong,
how's it gonna go wrong?
- I think it will go wrong
in probably in many ways,
it is very hard to predict what-
- In what direction,
going wrong direction.
- But again, if it's wrong, my prediction,
my meta prediction is also
going to be wrong too.
I don't know, I think it'll
be, maybe it's low adoption,
so not everyone will get on
board, you know, quickly.
So maybe a few in companies or sectors,
or will take a little longer to adopt.
But maybe this is the
way it will be wrong.
But in general, I think
they will take the stage
and free up some time from SREs
- Thank you
- our own happiness.
- Thanks for trusting us by the way.
And thanks for the sharing all this data.
I have my own predictions by the way,
and I've now worked in it
with agents for so long
that I'll give them to you in a minute.
But maybe to kind of summarize
in a way what we believe
or what may be the key takeaways.
I think that I truly believe
the impact of AI in production
is gonna be more than code.
Because yes, we can
generate maybe 80% of code,
but that hasn't allowed us
to move five times faster.
Once we manage to apply the same concepts
and the same reasoning abilities,
let's say crucial production,
and that's what the Resolve does,
we'll see that actually our
lives are gonna become easier
and gonna be able to move a lot faster.
Now that's not an easy problem, right,
like Josh showed and,
like Angelo described about,
you cannot build agents that you know,
maybe like an LLM on top of logs, right,
or on top of metrics.
These agents have to operate
these tools as a human
and they have to understand
the context of the entire system,
the way human would to be effective.
And finally the issuing
abilities of the agents.
And we're getting there, right?
The models are getting better.
The agents who are building
are becoming more effective,
have to be almost on
par with humans, right?
And sometimes they have to
be more effective, right?
I always compare the adoption of agents
in software or production
similar to maybe self-driving cars.
You know, we don't trust self-driving cars
if they're as good as humans, right?
They have to be safer than humans
to allow them to drive on the streets.
And I think the same is true for agents.
But, and I think we're getting there
and you know, if you ask me
what are my predictions about the future,
I think we're in an exponential
curve of improvement.
And the reason, by the way,
I asked Angelo about his prediction,
'cause I think most of us get
it wrong in the direction of,
we kind of extrapolate
based on what we've seen in the past.
And we're actually
maybe not, we don't see,
we're not as aggressive in our prediction
because we, it's hard for humans to see
what happens in an exponential curve.
I do think that
productivity gains from AI,
we'll exceed any other
technology that happened so far.
And actually will be in many ways,
maybe a solution out of
many problems we have,
as humanity even.
I do think that, you know,
more specifically when it comes
to software and technology,
I believe agents will be actually
doing more and more work today.
You know, the way Angelo was describing,
maybe agents respond to humans
or get triggered by an alert,
but I think they will start
working like, you know,
24/7 without actually complaining,
taking longer and longer tasks,
using more and more reasoning.
And then let's say a lot
more like this tedious,
laborious kind of effort into tokens
and, you know, delivering outcomes
and, you know, getting
essentially humans to operate.
And I think we're getting there,
at a high level of abstraction.
So in my view of all this
is that it's not like agents
are gonna take the work
of software engineers,
it's just that we're gonna be producing
like 10, a hundred times more technology.
And I think that's a
great thing for the world.
And with that, you know,
thanks for attending,
you can actually go and
use the Resolve today.
So if you scan that this QR code here,
it takes you to, you know, a signup page.
You can connect your tools if you want,
but there is also a sandbox
that you can play with right away.
And you can go into a
sandbox, play with it,
and go back and connect
your own tools, right?
And this is like our
preview of our, you know,
fully self-service product.
We can use it for free.
And if you like it, we'll
happy to talk to you more.